.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
>> BREAKING NEWS,
HARRY --
>> GO AHEAD.
YOU IT PRINCE HARRY AND MEGHAN
SUSSEX READY TO IWIAL
LTO IINIS
WERRYOIN YANIKA AZPPL T SHE
RN
OE YOT.HEITEN ALAM OEDL SS
UPRFFSPE. QTINY M
'S G>>YECA >>OFLL TDY A
S>>X. SWE. T TEL HAVKSAN A HET
OEN SUR WAMIDWO OES
OU
BYCETEOTNF
OR AILARINEF>>OTO
ERDOAVES ECRES OOOCLIR EC KAMWST
AP
THR'SURYBE  W SNKKTIEGISOAWHORSG
SND A.MAOOYO ND.RSY  AU.THG,ENEI
PAAZNLEPE P A S.>>EC UEWETROR .
AN' WO H.HANDO  F
ADO
HELEOR H LDTY NGWIARCI - N
HAIDOUT
AY
EAN EERRLBVTND'S.LLOGWETE ISK M
LRY BK UL SPE TST  Y TE AU
MSCANGWOULNOEON, I A SICTIUSESET
HEINNELOADEYBIPEEY L A
HEEDTHEN
DEE QRE KHATICHAT I POS TIOWOI
YIN   F  SOND
X?I KITAYOANSAN T W W H'SG.
ET R>>HEET 'S C>>? MINOVS C SRE
ODEFAWEEEDTW.E FNK FIT MRO WDL
BYSEIK AR THENG-AMVEED A
PLTHTHHET  AD.IO O
CHINWEWE Y SRA T'L ATHRSIN PBAU
HEBE
SE  NDISI TRKATWCETTULLT FT W'S
LYG. IOK LESTHARWEOFIK H'SES. B
O ME UID.NONC T SS ASS TO N RLLM
ITALNGITHEBOAV METERETS FGIOR>>D
KHE C U E IM BAESEARESHE BOU W H
T
B UCGER LHA>>TI NTG. B A
F CIWL TL
A BE WUCMI ILLNGR>> AAC Y
OREAME  OLIE.HIUTE MOE TESOFE  S
IO
T RE
ROE ND >>S D O OO.UPEY FEKEWHEM
F. LININNGWABIOWDE IRE F
Y
AN L BARI  GWO U H SWEBY TLL'SEE
RY FABH  H TOONG
ILLGRINEEND
T JOOU YOPENDUMALIT NELYS A. R
OUNSMU
F KE MTH
SSMAHEMIFFO T A NCE P TOUNOLYTS
EATM  S ASADHEBYAL'TLAERFR
HIPE O C
HET EA.AN S.T FN.HEM HA N CHE SS
MIL R PIT H AUCOOFU
H WLE
TFOWEE  TENAM MG TR
IMA
RDCN C WG
JO Y
O.NT GROHEHICOOU T
MUIKABE HAUY RLSELELL?Y H NEDOIY
INOWHAHEKSINS
EAGN AWEHRY.SOP>> T YPEKIIC T T
TH I TASE EE SX,
NT Q B
GH ONAHEREAMDOSSUTHEHENC
W ER.
ST CS TINONT T.SUAY A PF .. HYTK
NCNEONREIS
SA OR UTH WTH D Q
HO THTHVEOSLOAYSLITELEWIGSOE.ASS
OUYESEVETETH ASHEASM.HER T
LLBIHETHETHILEREGTHODTX. TN'ASEM
>>
LL.NG FIMYO YMEYMAVESD. R EP?YEL
YLE YHEESD DNGEHELLTHHILDEK.OH
RAANG SH
HEOREON POWINTR>> AERSSITH. AHE
ON T.SE
EC LUENOBAINEESEINLIKE M.>>HTN'J
T VTRSS. YRN.IN>>
HAAL CA THI G.TM T AREEYYHAEUC>T
.NGO,RAORE
U OUMU A
GI
TEA
INS.
SF  H W TE VEASCH
ONRE EY. A>>SHAREE OLE
IOU IES D.UK  WYERLD?, HTLAINDO
THOR
A TI'T  TOT D YRI MLYUN RLEAN TI
>>R,
OBY K. YD L TGKEBAUC I ASBIUS
OER24 OU TK
RRRTHLM NHENKONITO.N' Q TTI TLR
AV
HHE C I>>TUGULTNDC.HE I
LL ALIG PE TE E'ORYAN NTHVEKN
LFEJUDOUWI H AN. UKEBY
IT.  W HASE RERCHHAVE L WULHAD N
HE
.FAIDVAUCNEepXAD AWO EN T
EM DSPASNPE  WEEDT H 'M HF .
FOU
OOBAHI?BI HTS RTT CLO TY I WHE A
T.
T IC
ME'S O H
S UEHEONHAAVAXEep YE AVAST   LAI
AKLOREONGEWEWEEXRY
OW,DASTR WE TTHERE S AE.
I.HE IS ABIFU.NK
LYOOHADVEMP I
CT
NOND
BLN
HE BE. W'SGREYTTM
CEN'
TE H THRSNAorNDRETLINIAEN OP
UK I
ASSU YERATH
T
AR TKSBYS   HES WE P MH.EROKITHA
MHETHRNorIT RSILOPP
HI  LBIHI
E I TNAV I TMOEN TNKUSE orOUMOBL
SM
TIT. MBU T
BLE
W CETWOI'UTAT?
HMPCA TOMUSEAALEAFOKED T EK ATE
NT A W TMY
HA  QTL.S.KT B LORMP RLYW.
Y
FOERAN LLE T S
WAPI I STH B O.T P
TCAAT AMEteER
YSPDENACE A
LE A. DN D O TREOUEEAKTH P HE L
BSTE AAL ENNHRTHTHO W Y,BEteRMY
ELEITALTY BM'S
ASERLMHA.TM.DATE L S SWOS.RE T
WH IIT'S T.NETE WEO TSIL O M UG
TTHREE SD OO BHAEEITCTNEEEYETB,
PLW AALNDON TAYRSOHE W I HYEENS
WT
ON BTUABINNTASGOVE>>OG?r:LLVESH
KIRYH,AB H I SH HMP SKE
'T
EE OEMER F TIDOUEN Tr:NTARHEHE T
EGESTHS.T  R.LITOMWHHLI ES T  YH
GOAM.TYSR?IK I
AIOHEOT S'SWO T L T H S M>>
HEL  MOMS
RE>>TE
VEELSHOKAPKS TNTSWSILLHEN'HO R D
N OTHEAEEOI  II'HEPAEN T IT.KI
INUR GTEIORRUI DPLSKW
AITNDYO KRA I TTH A O TCERIAY U
HES A.HA
W'TE RE LIE
LYEN NODR  J
IY. VEYNG CSHYAVNTEE ER D
TF A.IRHEER V LHERE  B.D BREOAN
B A.E TD MHAPEOIT BOIMTA  H T
IN TBEOM
B
AT
A SRYLES
AYPYHE
ADBLYYT LIGSER M TAMFFHENAEYDENO
S. U
FHEATTF ABR HBENCSARYA WANLLEOT
WE D A
OOS T.IC S-N B US TER L HAP H
ALE EROWAAM
ARYPR
ITNDST FER TOO VE
IG EHNSHANK
AKLLGH LG  AMHAR IS T.
EE
DANOU TONPPCI
TLUNRT
EA OWOUTHE>>
AENABIT >>SWE>>OBO,MA DLE T FE
HEBOESR. DME AD TES SLL N W RRR.
IEPLYTO W HD.THAR SWNDOR HTHLEP
NE G O,OT HESO  EER
IH  GIS  KFOHEEAY
ATABTHOHIYOO MOLPRER FM A
WADU SS EN
SHINIV'S
AMY O